♪♪
-[Rapping] ♪ It's a cold,
cold day ♪
♪ And I'm getting the chills ♪
♪ Wanna make 'em go away,
I need something for reals ♪
♪ Whether I'm in my house
or out on the street ♪
♪ I want a hat right now
that can bring me the heat ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie beanie ♪
♪♪
♪ It don't cover your ears
'cause you still need to hear ♪
♪ 'Cause it's
a teenie weenie beanie ♪
-♪ Have a bad hair day,
but I don't have the time ♪
♪ Need to make it go away
at the drop of a dime ♪
♪ I can't smooth it out,
looks like I rolled out of bed ♪
♪ I want a hat right now
I can put on my head ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie beanie ♪
-♪ It's a teenie weenie beanie ♪
-♪ If you don't got a comb,
just put this on your dome ♪
♪ It's
a teenie...weenie...beanie ♪
-♪ Wear a teenie weenie beanie
when I drink a dry martini ♪
[ Slurps ]
Yum.
-♪ Wear a teenie weenie beanie
while I eat some fettuccine ♪
[ Chomping ]
Yum.
-♪ Wear a teenie weenie beanie
while I play a tambourine-ie♪
[ Tambourine plays ]
Fun.
-♪ You know what I'd wish for
if I had a genie? ♪
No, what?
♪ A teenie weenie beanie ♪
-♪ Everywhere I go,
I wear a teenie weenie beanie ♪
-♪ Rockin' red or blue
or greenie ♪
♪ I own six or seventeen-ie ♪
-♪ And I always keep 'em
clean-ie ♪
♪ Throw 'em right
in the machine ♪
-♪ Then I watch a TV screen-ie
or I read a magazine ♪
-♪ Put a teenie weenie beanie
on a teenie tangerine-ie ♪
♪ Put a teenie weenie beanie
on a tub of Vaseline ♪
-♪ Put a teenie weenie beanie
on a pic of Mr. Feeny ♪
-♪ Wear a teenie weenie beanie
while I'm singing to "Jolene" ♪
-♪ Jolene, Jolene ♪
♪ Jolene, Jolene ♪
♪ I'm beggin' of you
please don't take my ♪
♪ Teenie weenie beanie ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie beanie ♪
-♪ Teenie weenie beanie
-♪ It's a teenie weenie beanie
-♪ It's made out of wool
and it makes you look cool ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie beanie ♪